That fell apart quickly. Ooh.
It's just you and me, Logan.
I guess you know.
You know what?
That makes this a reunion for
X-Men Origins Reunite.
Yeah,
Welcome back everyone
Maximum effort
There's a new report
that Marvel is bringing back Liev
Schreiber's Sabretooth for Deadpool three.
Now there's video with them
having a reunion.
Making all these jokes
makes a lot more sense.
the last time we saw
them was in Wolverine origins,
if you can believe it was that long ago,
which Ryan Reynolds, Hugh Jackman
all made fun of
in this video when they all got back
together, having a big reunion.
there were actually a bunch of cool
deleted scenes
and sabretooth in the Logan movie
that they can also pay off now.
So if you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
I'll be doing videos for everything.
and we will start
getting some more information about
what's actually happening with the movies
pretty soon they're going to be
so many cameos during Deadpool
three in Avengers six Secret Wars.
You to imagine like a version of Daryl
just running around in the background
with his crossbow,
like All Wrong Universe.
But hey, look, it's Daryl.
Speaking of which.
Thank you to AMC in The Walking Dead
people for asking to sponsor this video.
They just premiered The Walking Dead
Daryl Dixon series.
It's meant to be a sequel
to the original Main
Walking Dead series, telling the story.
What happens to Daryl after the events
of The Walking Dead season 11 finale
probably one of the biggest differences
between this and the other sequel series
and spinoffs from the main series
is that it takes place
in a totally different country.
as you can see from the trailer, the Daryl
Dixon series takes place in France.
The series begins with a time jump
after the Walking Dead season 11 finale,
Daryl washes up on the shores of France
without any memory of how he got there.
He's always his trusty crossbow.
never go anywhere without the crossbow.
Even if you get knocked out
and dumped on the other side of the world,
still bring the crossbow with you.
So he begins having to piece together
what happened to him
and how he wound up in France
and how to survive in this foreign country
They've already renewed it for season two.
Season one will have six episodes.
They already released episode one.
As of me posting this video and new
episodes are released every Sunday.
Like normal,
The episodes will all be on the main
AMC channel, just like normal, or
you can watch them on any of your devices
using the AMC plus streaming service.
So I'll put a link down to the description
below.
Be sure to check it out.
Find out how Darryl Dixon
gets himself out of this situation.
I know there are a lot of people out there
that would love to see
a version of Norman Reedus
be the new MCU version of Ghost Rider.
Maybe we'll hear something about that
pretty soon, too.
right now, as a me posting this video,
they paused all filming on
all the upcoming movies for the strikes.
They were about halfway done
with Deadpool three when that happened,
so there's still a lot of stuff left
for them
to finish on that particular movie.
That's why you've been hearing
about all these cameos.
Hopefully they wind up working that out.
The delays don't cause any scheduling
issues, making people drop out.
Shawn Levy was also joking in real life
about other chemistry between Hugh Jackman
and Ryan Reynolds. Like,
Oh, it's going to be amazing.
but it is a some of the cameos
do sound a little overblown.
He didn't necessarily deny
that they were all in the movie,
but he did say if all these people wind up
being in the movie
that people think are in the movie,
it'll be one of the best movies
of all time,
which is basically him saying that,
oh yeah, we got a bunch of good people
in this movie.
they're bringing the Sabretooth character
back for a couple reasons.
Obviously leave Schreiber's version
just because he was the bigger,
better version
of the character in As a More History
with Hugh Jackman's version of Wolverine.
the original version of Sabertooth
and X-Men 2000 was played by Tyler Main.
He did a totally fine job,
but I always felt like leave Schreiber,
which is a better actor in general,
Even though we all clown on Wolverine
Origins script, we're not doing him
or Hugh Jackman
any favors with the dialog that they had.
yeah,
it was a very frustrating experience.
Did you get the part
because you were already
sort of already attached to Deadpool,
or was that a total coincidence?
Yeah, it was.
I was already attached
to the Deadpool movie.
We hadn't at that point
written the script yet, but you know that
that came along and I
and I was
it was sort of like play Deadpool
in this movie
or we'll get someone else to.
And I just said, I'll, I'll do it,
but it's the wrong version.
It was Deadpool wasn't correct in it
so it was during a writer's strike,
the great WGA writer's strike.
So there was no
we were in the middle of production.
There was no writers, no anything.
I mean,
when I show every line I have in the movie
I just wrote myself because it's in
the script that we had, it just said, Wade
Wilson shows up, talks really fast.
Ryan Reynolds Still clowns on
his Wolverine origins version of Deadpool.
In addition to all of his Green
Lantern stuff literally had himself
killing those versions of himself
during Deadpool two Post-Credits scene.
very apropos
as his clowning on Wolverine origins,
he says a lot of the script problems
that they had with
that were because they were
in the middle of a strike
when they were making that movie.
So they couldn't have any actual writers
on set to punch it up.
I'm not quite
as worried about Deadpool three
because that's kind of
going through the same thing.
Just because Ryan Reynolds
has so much more control over the movie
and they're doing a much better job
with the actual scripts.
one of the things behind the scenes,
those those X-Men movies
is that Bryan Singer, the X-Men producers
didn't really care that much
about the Sabertooth character in general
or the Tyler made version the character.
That's why he didn't come back during
X-Men two, United or X-Men The Last Stand,
then when they got to the X-Men Origins
Wolverine movie, Tyler Main claims
that they recast him
because Leave Schreiber looked way
more like Hugh Jackman in real life
and they wanted to play up the fact
that they were biological brothers
but just injured.
I think they felt like Leave
Schreiber was a bigger get for them
when they got to the sequel to that
the Wolverine movie done by James Mangold
Leaf Schreiber claims
the reason that they didn't bring him back
for that is because they couldn't
figure out a way to fit sabretooth
into the narrative of that movie.
because it was all about Wolverine
in Japan and his history there.
And then him in present
day is able to just
really have a connection
with any of the characters in that movie
besides Wolverine.
then when they got to the Logan movie,
which James Mangold also did,
he was going to be in that film,
but they sort of cutting it down for Tom,
and basically he wound up
being a deleted scene.
There were a couple of different
deleted scenes that mentioned Sabretooth
or featured Sabretooth
Hugh Jackman said that he felt like
one of the best things in Wolverine
origins was leave Schreiber's Sabretooth.
So he was looking for a way
to include him in the Logan movie.
But what wound up happening
is that the script got so big,
like it turned into a much bigger movie
that they just couldn't
find a place for him.
Originally what was going to happen
is they go to the casino in Oklahoma
and Sabretooth was going to be running.
One of the casinos is going to become
very wealthy later in the timeline.
so they they intended for Wolverine
to have a bit of a reunion with him
when they went to the actual casino.
But the movie just got too big
and they went ahead to delete that scene.
there was another deleted scene
later in the movie
when he's talking to one of the kids
at the end where they escape
from the transmission company
trying to experiment with their powers.
And he tells the kid that
everything in the comics that X 23 had
been reading was actually real,
which was a big reversal
of what he had said
to earlier in the movie,
claiming that it was all just nonsense.
But as he's laying there on the edge
of death, he tells the kid the truth.
It was all real.
And Sabretooth who he mentions was in
the comic book was also real.
so they had all this great buildup work
that they did with the Wolverine
Sabretooth
the relationship during Wolverine origins,
they never really got the opportunity
to pay that off.
Even though Hugh Jackman said
that he was one of his favorite parts
of that actual movie dip for.
Three comes along now and provides the
perfect opportunity for them to do that.
It's meant to be a big swan song
for all the classic X-Men,
the Fox Marvel movie characters.
That's why
they're the ones that they're
mostly bringing back
when they started announcing
all the cameos, people were like,
What about saber tooth?
Are they going to bring him back to?
this also gives them the opportunity
to do a more comic book, accurate
looking version of Saber Tooth,
because that's the whole vibe
that they're going with
for all the returning X-Men and Fantastic
Four characters Is it
They're all wearing costumes
that look more comic booky back
when they released this video, them
doing their big reunion.
At the time,
I thought that it was just them doing
a fundraiser for charity
during the pandemic
and just telling a couple of jokes
during it.
But based on the timing,
Ryan Reynolds was probably in the middle
of writing Deadpool
while that was happening.
So it sounds like he was working
all these characters
into the movie, talking to these actors
behind the scenes about coming back
while they were doing this
rewatching the video.
Now, with all of them,
it makes a lot more sense
why they'd be doing
that together like this.
Knock, knock.
Whoa.
So many stars. Is that.
Why was that? Ian McKellen?
Brian,
the cast and I were all just reminiscing
about the movie
that we were all in together.
I hear you.
You know, I love that that movie.
I hope it's okay if I join.
I figured we were all in X-Men together.
X-Men Origins. Yeah.
Always good seeing you, Ryan.
I actually invited a few others.
Hey, guys.
Hey, everyone.
So many timelines.
It's like a recap of Knots Landing.
Two professors, one cop.
What's happening?
It's just like the X-Men movies.
You know, it doesn't matter.
Oh, sorry. I actually thought
this was the Game of Thrones reunion.
You know, Tyrion Lannister was in an X-Men
film.
Okay, bye.
Actually, have a James Bond reunion soon.
Oh, God.
Meeting Split Reunion track.
I love you, Patrick Stewart.
love the way that they all clown.
On Ryan Reynolds during this too.
Like they can't stand him
and everyone bails on the chat
the minute that he appears
in their conference
call like, Oh, peace out, got to go.
Got something else I had to do?
none of these new reports
say what saber tooth is actually doing
during the events of Deadpool three.
But since all the X-Men characters
who are coming back
are supposed to be part of this 838
universe storyline
right now, without more information,
I assume that he's also going to be
on that same earth with the rest of them.
the other big report
you probably saw recently
is that they're actually introducing
a concept of battle world from secret wars
during the movie.
And the movie will be a direct lead in
for Avengers six secret wars in the MCU.
supposedly during the events of the movie,
like towards the end of the film,
the multiverse will all
but finish collapsing.
The incursions will start taking out
the remaining universes.
Then Mobius
and the TVA characters are going to start
saving as many characters
as they can, like the returning X-Men,
Fantastic Four characters
and putting them on Battle World
that might be what's happening
during the events of the footage
that we saw of Wolverine fighting Deadpool
with the remnants of the 20th Century Fox
logo in the background,
the Void planet from Loki
that might wind up being
their version of battle world that they're
talking about in all these reports.
that's already
kind of the vibe of the void in general.
Like it's a dumping ground for remnants
from a bunch of alternate timelines,
alternate universes
you can kind of see the similarities
to the 1980s Secret
Wars version of Battle World in the during
the more modern secret wards,
the plots of those versions of secret
wards were very different,
but they both had a version
of Battle World
where the characters
were brought to do battle.
It's just the reason
why they fought each other
was meant to be very different
in each version.
the 1980 Secret Wars was engineered
by the Beyond,
who just brought a bunch of the main
616 universe characters to battle world
to fight each other for his amusement.
It was basically him
just messing with everyone.
It wasn't meant to be a multiverse story,
though, which is the main universe
they actually did.
A version is during the 1990s.
Spider-Man, the animated series,
the more modern version.
The Secret Wars was like
a full multiverse, incursions
kind of thing,
destroying all the universes.
The beyond was race
was trying to destroy the multiverse.
Doctor Strange doctor doom molecule man
Try to save it until Doctor Doom
eventually takes the power of the orders
to become God Emperor Doom
and then combines all the remnants
of the remaining universes together
to create a version of battle world,
bringing a bunch of multiverse
characters to it.
because Deadpool three is now supposedly
directly setting up secret wars,
that probably means some of the movie
takes place
after the events of Loki season two.
So we might see some Easter eggs for that
during the Loki season two episodes.
cannot wait to see how Loki and Sylvie
are going to destroy the multiverse
even faster this time.
Let me know in the comments though.
What do you want them to do
with Sabretooth during Deadpool
three and which other characters do
you want to see come back for Secret Wars?
I literally just did another Loki Season
2 trailer video
with a bunch of new footage.
Episodes will start pretty soon.
I'll be doing videos for everything,
just like season one.
Click here to watch that and click here
for my Ahsoka Episode 5 Video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone. Stay safe and maximum effort!